joined me now is the party's chair
annalize dots so a very good morning to
you Annelise Dodds
um I don't know if you've seen our
political editors interview with Rishi
sulang but in it he wouldn't commit to a
particular Target for net migration but
he did make it clear that he wants the
numbers to come down does labor want net
migration to go up or down
well actually laborer believes that
setting a net migration Target isn't
sensible and it appears even Richie
sunac knows that however what he's not
done is creates an immigration system
that works for our country you know
labor said for a very long time that we
need to have a point space system one
which is actually integrated and Works
hand in hand with our approach to
training answer skills at the moment the
two areas are simply not working
together why is that a problem it's an
issue because we've got parts of our
economy where we desperately need to be
training up people in our own country
you know we can think of for example
some of those areas of high tech we can
think of areas within also our NHS where
I mean it's wonderful we can access
those International doctors for example
but why on Earth did we see the
government actually cutting the number
of training places in medical schools
last year this is the law
so sorry to interrupt but do you want
that migration to go up or down
well as I said it's not sensible to have
that kind of a target-based approach
because it's just a general idea of
where labor stands on migration do you
want to see it go up are you comfortable
with it going up or would you rather say
it come down
well what we would see if we had an
immigration system that was working
properly would be potentially in some
areas where there's a short-term need
for skills you could see in the short
term actually people who were coming in
increasing in number but for the medium
and long term a reduction because we
would be training people up in our own
country as I said we've not had that
unfortunately under the conservatives
we've got skill shortages and those
shortages not being filled because
there's not been the domestic upskilling
that needs to take place and you know
labor has set out plans for this when it
comes to our NHS for example plans to
double the number of medical school
training places not actually reducing
them as the conservatives have done
that's a sensible way to deal with this
to actually marry up a points-based
immigration system with skills and
training and that's what effect keeper
would deliver as Home Secretary so case
normal said this week that he plans to
revisit it's the brexit deal and secure
a closer trading relationship with the
EU will that mean a rise in migration
from the EU
well no it wouldn't actually because
labor has been clear that we don't want
to see a return to free movement what we
do want to see is actually a situation
that works for our country we have a
ridiculous situation currently in many
of our ports huge amounts of red tape to
really holding back British businesses
they've been linked to also higher costs
of food for example with food inflation
having been higher in our country than
in many other comparable countries so
what do we need to do with very
practical measures you know for example
you've got lots of countries outside the
EU that actually have Veterinary
agreements with the EU Australia for
example that would cut away a lot of
that red tape and bureaucracy it's a
really sensible pragmatic move that
should be taken you know labor is
looking forwards on all of this not
backwards we're looking towards the
needs of our economy what our country
needs that's what we would prioritize
um I wondered if I can get your view on
a report a special report that we've
done today looking at absenteeism by
children in schools more than double the
number of these so-called ghost children
in schools compared to pre-pandemic
levels what's your reaction to that
I think these figures are incredibly
concerning and I think they show that
the approach of the Prime Minister of
course previously he said that he'd
maxed out on Covert recovery that was
the wrong approach we should have seen a
proper covered recovery plan in our
schools and our education system for
children as labor had called for but we
also now desperately need to see that
mental health support in schools that
labor has been calling for you know we
have set out how we would pay for that
we pay for it by getting rid of some of
those loopholes in our tax system we
would then use that to actually be
supporting children in school because
when you look at why children aren't
coming into school I mean there are a
range of factors but one of them does
appear to be issues around mental ill
health and we really need to grip onto
this because for every day every week
every month that a child isn't in school
that can ultimately affect them for the
rest of their lives this should be
prioritized by government but it hasn't
been prioritized by the conservatives
okay well Annelise Dodds thanks very
much indeed for your time this morning
we appreciate it thank you thank you